no matter how much we may look forward
to new episodes of our favorite shows
there's no such thing as a perfect TV
series and even the most popular and
critically acclaimed small screen hits
have made some really really awful
choices the entire sixth season of The
Walking Dead led up to one moment comic
fans had already broken the news to TV
viewers Glenn would die beneath the
bloody baseball bat of Meighan leader of
the saviors as the season entered its
final moments though all we got was well
this you can breathe you can lick you
can cry basically it was the world's
least satisfying cliffhanger did Glynn
die or did somebody else find themselves
at the business end of Lucille was it
someone we even cared about the
showrunners defended the non reveal by
saying it was done in the interest of
storytelling but it wouldn't have been
quite so bad were it not for a blunder
earlier in the season for a few episodes
dead made a big deal about Glenn Bean
well dead which he wasn't the zombie
epic never had to fake us out about
mortality before but the introduction of
goofy camera tricks had already left a
rotten taste in everyone's mouth just
give us the gory goods and a heaping
helping of the fields or get out of the
way the writers of The Big Bang Theory
have always made the Nerds the guys that
you root for even if they make dumb
mistakes they're generally not
reprehensible jerks even Sheldon's
obnoxious idiosyncrasies are generally
charming and the romance between Leonard
and Penny is probably one of the sweeter
things on TV so the eighth season finale
was the ultimate bummer
on their way to get married in Vegas
Leonard admits to penny that he'd kissed
another girl gut-punching everyone in
the audience who believes in true love
what did you do nothing really
it was just kissing not only is it weird
hurdle to throw in front of the
characters but it's also strangely out
of character for the show which never
really gets heavier than the death of
Howard's mom and that was more of a
tribute to the late actress Carol and
Susie than a significant plot point
turning every nerd Leonard into a legend
making the audience marinate on it all
summer long sucked why can't we just
have nice things
friends was really about two things the
titular friends hanging out with each
other and those
friends dating an endless parade of
people who weren't as good as their
friends to that end two of the friends
Chandler and Monica married within the
circle while Phoebe found love with Mike
who was able to infiltrate the court
group because he was played by Paul Rudd
the most charming man on earth putting
off that moment when they inevitably got
Ross and Rachel back together for good
friends writers killed sometime in the
final years of the show by trying to
make Rachel and Joey a thing let us
repeat that again someone thought it was
a good idea to put this man let's check
out check out it's like it's coming
right at me and this woman together oh
god imagine how their kids would turn
out on some level it made sense because
they were the two friends who dated
around the most on every other level it
made no sense because there had never
been any heat between those two
characters it was just weird and before
long Rachel and Joey realized they were
meant to be surprise friends rendering
the whole plot arc and exercise and
wheel spinning oh well at least it
spawned some of our favorite Gunther
moments Rachel oh how I Met Your Mother
you had so much potential you could have
gone down as one of the most consistent
sitcoms of all time were it not for that
last season of course sure fans
eventually learned that the woman of
Ted's dreams was a gal named Tracy but
the actual finale of the show
found him middle-aged and rekindling his
romance with friend and fellow main
character Robin the show's provocative
thesis a person can have two great loves
in their life if you're wondering where
the hell all that came from well so
we're a lot of viewers the harsh reality
is How I Met Your Mother wasted most of
its final season which takes place
mostly in the hours leading up to the
wedding of Robin and Barney so much time
was spent puttering around that the
finale episode crammed in a ton of
stories in the passage of many years
that could have been explored in depth
over the course of the season these
briefly mentioned things include Ted and
Tracy getting to know each other having
their kids
Tracy dying and how Barney and Robin get
divorced so you know the stuff that
would have actually made us care instead
we got everything I
and everything I am is scores oof
way to drop the ball and pull a lost
guys Dexter dared to go where no other
show had dared go before it was a series
where the protagonist was a serial
killer
the writers actually got viewers to root
for a man consumed by his desire to
murder and they made him a sympathetic
character because he only really ever
killed really bad people usually Dexter
really made good use of its home on
Showtime depicting graphic murders and
mutilations and whatnot desensitizing
fans over time to all of that horrific
and violent imagery where could a show
like that possibly go after that incest
one of Dexter's few allies in the world
was his sister Deborah a Miami homicide
detective in the show's sixth season
finale
Deborah not only finds out her brother
is a serial killer but realizes that she
loves him romantically he's technically
her adoptive brother but still that's
almost as hard to stomach as well you
are the love of my life